okay yeah perfect do you ever just get
one hot ear yeah all the time
you know your ears varies your smile oh
god it's happening
Thanks yep hi guys with your favorite
Hart and Hannah Hart
yeah in honor of the fact that we are
doing another round of no filter shows
oh we've already shot two videos one for
memory channel one for a national the
reserve Amanda no hunter show tour is an
honor
mamrie Hart spot oh my gosh book calm
and free water now it comes out May 24
May 26 26 - I'm see us on tour the links
to buy tickets with all the shows five
of them through Chicago New York
Philadelphia Seattle and San Francisco
are in the description below so in honor
a friendship and an honor of us about to
go on tour I thought we would do the
emojis challenge what is that what is
that everyone's been doing this emoji
tag where they pick five emojis that
most describe them
I thought that we should turn it into a
game where each of us we choose three
emojis that we think best describe us
and three emojis that we think best
describe our dogs Oh
and then we're each going to try and
guess the three emojis for the person
and the dog and then the person at the
end of this that has the least
correction associations of emoji is
going to have to do something
embarrassing on stage at one of our
nofilter shows good I need this looked
at by my lawyer first we're gonna choose
our emojis for ourselves and our dogs
we'll figure it out as we go guys that's
just light it's got a figure and as you
girls know maybe figured out a lot of
things in her book I'm sorry are we
getting food delivered to our door cuz
that was seamless ooh ah she's like how
dare you I would never be the eggplant
okay honey good she's religious
Oh oh my god we're better and closer Oh
Olli if you fart so help me die
Oh what is being is all about come on
how human beings could be bud she'd ride
you like a samurai nine sweets go down
the line and we'll guess mamrie first
short thank you a night now and take a
paper and we try and think of the three
from memory and three for being gotta go
you are not as small as you want to be
for you to the choir yeah I'm feeling it
multi-feed think about dude that's your
mistake
I know I'm sorry that's her mistake she
needs to let us in today
so from mamrie the first one I chose is
the woman wiggler hand like this first
one I chose is sassy dancing lady cuz
Mimi loves to party
ding ding yes that's one that's what
that says he has none
damn it I'm gonna get the point then I
put the poop emoji I put the two viewers
cheering I didn't know there was a
mirror Cheers
also I've never used the poop emoji in
my life it's crass pot yes so that's the
last one I chose is my own lyrics
eyes are like come on that's a good bit
I did cry laughing cuz maybe always
cries when she left I did
I did the well and then I did a
cartwheel Oh what am I don't know me at
all
now onto beans my first one was boiling
it sounds like it's a no-go that's a
no-go
okay my first one was the face it makes
like hmm Oh smart
yeah no my second one wasn't waving like
goodbye get out of my house
these are your emotions when dealing
with pain yeah go BA I thought my second
one's all right cause we love being so
much damn it and then the last one I
have is looking one zze oh I left my
name is flamingo girl we going for
because she's an old fascinating yeah
that's the heart I have a praise rate
and I have some means she's such a mean
you're unbelievable two point Anna
all right now mamrie and you and I
trying to figure out Hannah and Ollie
mm-hmm BAM like man record I got some
any other oh okay don't put a photo book
all right like advances I got a heart
first first one I chose for Hannah Hart
smile comes with the medical mask you
always think you're sick all the time
no no I have the monkey doing wait Oh
ask you oh but no monkey I love this
monkey I have a glass of red wine yes
yes got one I've got the armor does this
uh
and then my last one is the face it's
like oh that's my that is my favorite
smiley one but no jacket legs you know a
company
nope no no what are your sunglasses cuz
I'm so cool okay my glass and the point
well I almost chose a thumbs up yeah I
always do that may see you much
differently yeah
ollie I have the superior smiley face no
diamond way with you know I have heart I
really fit nope I have every oh no the
wind really farts okay be all the things
you practically yes always emojis were
angel quail and Bailey angel Luke baby
is my favorite girl man that's my
favorite perfume Angelou babies are any
speakers now do chew guessing mind okay
so you're great uh-huh mmm oh you know
what you know what maybe that oh you
know what that's what I'm doing
got it I guess me first rate I have
dancing around a lady no I have a person
that's not making happy eyes where
you're going yes I have Easter Island
then oh gee you're very stoic I am
searching I like wailing well no the
label your hair done you get your hair
cut off I do and yes I got two out of
your three you know - and then the whole
that way damn going with space one okay
yeah okay now for goose I have I have a
I have a double joy um no I almost put
the devil but
and no not that but I appreciate I have
another devil I'm just kidding I am uh
really no I have fiery Cooper we will
heart
I like smiley face cuz she loves so hard
I don't know angry face the red Hey the
scary we face one
screams all day long barks a tip no no
you have a brush
well I had a crash and I'm family and I
are tied we both have to do something on
stage and no filter that I guess we'll
leave up to Hannah to decide shall we do
it this in Chicago yeah Levi come in
chicago cubs chicago cuz we're gonna do
a Chicago burn your mark leave some
comments down below of suggestions of
what Hannah should make us do on stage
at the Chicago show and don't forget to
buy your tickets if you are in or around
any of the cities and go to why this
book calm over your favorite cut yeah hi
booboo burlier sarah burp emoji